do you ever look back on all the people
you've worked with and go man I can't
believe that guy or that woman didn't
become a star like I really thought that
person was going to Skyrocket
you know working with someone and going
this person this person's got it and
then you're like huh whatever happened
with them I mean they work and stuff but
I always thought they'd be way bigger
right right
interesting right it is interesting to
think about
I wonder if people say that about me
okay no I think everybody thought oh
she's she's a star I think when you have
talent and looks
both you you you're it's a slam dunk
with me it was like I had a little
talent I was okay looking
so it was like I had to really push the
talent part I had to really show people
no no
because I always were fishing for a
compliment no I swear to God because
listen I always say this but like look
when I when I was on Smallville I mean
look around me everybody was way better
looking than me would you attest to that
Ryan admit it
are you fishing still I'm not fishing
Tom Kristen uh Whitney uh everyone was
good looking because it was a WB show CW
Show and that includes you oh yeah right
anyway it's not about me but
um yeah but can you think of anybody or
someone who you were like no this
person's not gonna be I or all right I I
don't I didn't expect this person to be
such the star they are how about that I
I honestly can't think of a person but
I'm also somebody who like
in my younger days when I was working I
underestimated everybody and now I'm
like the opposite where I'm like oh my
God everybody's so amazing do you know
what I mean because I also have perspect
I think it comes with perspective of
career of how hard this is of like the
miracle of like what is it five percent
of members of sag are working like it's
hard to do what we do and to
consistently get jobs
but I don't know I've never worked with
anybody where I was like oh that
person's gonna be ginormous
um